today officially marks 20 years since
Princess Diana's tragic death and while
her sons are marking the occasion in
private the public is paying tribute to
the woman who will forever be the
people's princess today in Paris at the
sight of Diana's fatal car crash and in
London at Kensington Palace where she
lived mourners laid flowers in her
memory 20 years ago in the days
following Diana's death the British
people were grieving and eager to hear
from the Queen our Mark Steines was
there here Buckingham Palace record
crowds have gathered outside the gates
to catch a glimpse of the Queen and hear
her message perhaps the most important
message of her 45 year reign we have all
been trying to help William and Harry
come to terms with a devastating loss
but they and the rest of us have
suffered the spotlight turns on the boy
who would be king tomorrow on NBC Prince
William reflects on the day he and his
brother had to walk behind their
mother's casket I thought Paris had
brought us up turn to understand that as
best we can but there is this element of
duty and the responsibility that you
know you have to do things you don't
want to do but I'd say when it becomes
that personal as walking behind your
mother's funeral cortege it's um you
goes to another level of duty you know I
just kept thinking about what she would
want and offensive is she was there with
us I felt like she was almost walking
along beside us to get us through
you